oleg orlov n'a pas encore eu le temps de
nettoyer la porte de son appartement
ça fait quelques jours qu'il tente
d'absorber ce triste décor des aides et
sa photo tel un criminel
collaborateurs rentre chez toi lille
affiche à 69 ans ceux des terrans de la
défense des droits de la personne en
russie pensait que les années les plus
sombres de son pays était derrière lui
mais il avait tant
c'est un retour au totalitarisme tel que
nous l'avons vécu jeunes dit oleg qui
comme membre du groupe mémorial s'est
battu toute sa vie pour la justice mais
c'est à refaire
z peinture et a même sa porte est
beaucoup plus qu'une lettre et dans le
contexte elle donne froid dans le dos
devenu symbole de l'évasion rue c'est de
la propagande militaire elle sert
désormais à intimider ceux qui dénoncent
publiquement la guerre de vladimir
poutine en ukraine et le cas de legs est
loin d'être le seul
ce genre d'intimidation fruit de la
délation se multiplient
tous les jours les aides apparaît sur
les portes des citoyens dont
l'opposition est connu comme dimitri
ivanov un étudiant engagé dont la chaîne
télégramme diffuse de l'information
indépendante
le graffiti qui dit 'mon trahit pas ta
patrie est apparu sur sa porte avant le
week end et sur celle de plusieurs de
ses amis il ne sait pas qui en sont les
auteurs ni comment ils ont trouvé son
adresse mais c'est terrifiant
surgit peur dit il ces lois répressives
nous menace de 15 ans de prison la
plupart des affiches portent d'ailleurs
le numéro des articles du code pénal qui
prévoit des peines pour toute action qui
discrédite le travail des soldats russes
mais oleg orlov dit qu'il ne se taira
pas pour autant
honnêtement je continuerai parce que
j'ai honte de mon pays et mes
concitoyens il se met la tête dans le
sable et ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec la guerre ont peur d'ouvrir la
bouche
il y en a encore comme lui qui osent
manifester ne serait ce que quelques
minutes pour dénoncer la barbarie
mais c'est tolérance zéro dans toute la
russie
cet homme a été arrêté samedi avec une
simple pancarte qui disait que les
enfants méritent de vivre en paix il n'y
a tout simplement plus aucune tribune
pour s'exprimer librement
même les contournable festival du
documentaire de moscou n'a pas échappé à
cette nouvelle censure quand son
organisateur le réalisateur vital
immense qui a été insulté puis agressée
en public
l'homme qui l'a aspergée portait lui
aussi un z ceuxqui n'est pas surpris il
faut vaincre la peur a dit mme steed sur
le vice
président
soit il dit est sur vous
comme les ukrainiens le fond c'est à
nous aussi de se défendre il faut se
sauver nous mêmes de cette tyrannie faut
le faire pour nos enfants c'est plus
vrai est nécessaire que jamais mais oled
ne sais pas s'il vivra assez longtemps
pour retrouver une liberté qu'il a déjà
connue
et
selon lui aucun autre pays qui s'est
libérée du totalitarisme a replongé
dedans comme le fait la russie
aujourd'hui à quoi bon nettoyer sa porte
il sait que tôt ou tard ils reviendront